days better days I'm not so far away
[Music]
such a great song who loved that song
Headley's cageless torah rolls on
tonight and the boys are performing in
Grand Prairie Alberta but before they
hit the road for their cross-canada tour
Cheryl got a tour behind the scene then
of course we begin with the scariest
place of all the boys dressing room all
right I'm back with Jacob put your
pokeball and we are going to go on a
tour a backstage tour of the cageless
tour you see what I did there
a few skits so this is our dressing room
how nice it's pretty low-key we like to
keep it very by the knockdown search in
effects you've been warned okay oh it's
like a visual consent okay not a thing
and yes so this is our jams these are
this is kind of our way we'll chill
before show and probably in the middle
of the day but I also the smell in here
I like this it's not socks and like no
it's not soft at all it's very mellow
it smells like soy natural soy that's an
actual BC highway sign that we got the
Crowsnest highway is the highway between
Vancouver and Calgary so it goes through
the Rocky Mountains and the little town
of Headley is a town you pass by on the
Crowsnest highway can you tell me about
this the dreamcatcher achievement award
which is [ __ ] the dreamcatcher I don't
know if I want you are now
the dreamcatcher achievement award is
something we present to a crew member on
tour each tour every year for
outstanding achievement in the field of
being a complete tune-up very nice you
touch it with your hand it's incredible
yeah you use your own hands to touch it
all right what else okay so this is
backstage so we're going so this is
where we come up every night so we'll
walk up there'll be videos playing and
you'll start to hear the crowd getting
pumpkins we'll come back here and then
we'll get prepared this tree is very
important to this album and this tour
the tree in the album cover is actually
the whole setting is our where we record
down in Los Angeles we've recorded a lot
of Headley albums there and it's kind of
like our second home I started to obsess
with what's called infrared photography
which is where you take a photo and then
you remove the green colors and what
you're left with is always hot pink and
I thought it was so ironic because hey
just is the title but here's this like a
little like vacation set yeah sense this
is kind of where I may be growing up
playing bands playing them in bars
playing theatres playing in small areas
I was always quite inhibited by how much
space we had having this really big open
space for me it's like it's like my it's
very important right smarter person how
do you not fall off the edge I don't
even get the white paint but like have
you ever had any close calls I don't
know you're pretty good I'm okay I'm I'm
kind of pretty dried but this is one so
we can knock on it because the tour's
just starting and I'm not close you
think you're gonna be totally hitting
about whether or not I'm gonna fall off
or not